[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
and i am joined with someone i've never
met but is probably the person i'd most
like to meet
of all the guests that have uh graced my
presence or
graced me with their presence rather on
the end of the impossible
podcast and it's a it's a friend of mine
who's a dear human being it's steven
strogatz
one of the simultaneously most humble
but most accomplished people
that i've ever known he got his phd in
applied mathematics from harvard
and he's currently the jacob gould
sherman professor of applied mathematics
at cornell
which what almost would have been my
alma mater steve had you guys accepted
me
uh the two times i applied so you know
well had nothing to do
wow brian that's a very nice
introduction i i feel the same way i
can't wait to meet you in person
it's going to be great we were supposed
to meet about a year ago
when i was supposed to come to cornell
to give a colloquium for the astronomy
department many good friends over there
and uh something
came up there was some cancellation of
most world travel
but i am hoping that the invitation will
remain good and that someday
i will be able to uh to meet you in
person there and
i'm actually secretly hoping to get you
here maybe by proffering
uh an invitation uh during next january
when
perfect ithaca is not the greatest i
mean it is a travel destination but
usually not
in general well nothing nothing compares
to san diego
you start off this wonderful book which
we're going to talk about although not
exclusively i'm going to try out a whole
bunch of crackpot theories i'm going to
talk about the art of
podcasting because you are also a
raccontour and a podcast host
extraordinaire
from whom i've learned much but i want
to start off with
infinite powers your delightful latest
book in addition to sync
and the joy of x yeah some of your more
most famous books
the latest book was also new york times
bestseller and it's just such a
beautiful book but it starts off
with someone that i regret steve that i
never met
and it's herman woke who wrote the winds
of war
the kane mutiny and i actually had a
chance to meet him because he
uh is the namesake of the woke chair of
and it's woke not w-k-o-k-e
like some people might be hearing it uh
we won't talk about politics
today but a w-o-u-k
and he lived in palm springs and he had
the
chair called the hermann walk chair of
um of
judaic studies here at uc san diego it
still exists and um
and i never met him and i was always
hungry i'll meet him you know i'll take
the time it's a couple hour drive
but he's always so vivacious and vibrant
i never thought it would uh
be a limitation to my being able to
visit and that shows you how
that the truism steve that no one is as
dumb as an intellectual
because i never met him and he passed
away about three years ago at the age of
103 but you open this book
with a recollection or a statement about
him and how he spoke to richard feynman
i wonder if you could if you could
recount that
and then um and and then tell us how why
was that sort of the impetus for this
book
sure well yeah um so herman woke was
really the one of the greatest most
popular american
novelists of my parents generation so
the world war ii generation needed
someone to tell their story
and he had been a sailor he was in the
navy
and he wanted to write something like
war and peace for
you know for americans um but hopefully
you know something that'd be popular and
readable so he he was researching his
big book about world war
ii and uh he thought he should include
something about the manhattan project
right i mean the building of the atomic
bomb
did end the war in at least in japan
and so he wasn't sure who to talk to
about this but people told him well you
got to go to caltech
and while you're there you have to talk
to this guy named fineman so woke
who who came from a background in you
know literature history philosophy the
humanities
um goes to see this tremendous physicist
richard feynman
and as they talk they start to realize
they have a lot in common they're both
jewish guys they both grew up in new
york
you know they um both love to tell
stories have good senses of humor and so
they
their and of course feynman had also
served in the war he was a very young
guy working on the manhattan project
like in his early 20s
but they also have some big differences
that the woke was
devout orthodox whereas feynman was
extremely atheistic so
anyway they're kibitzing and they're
having a good time talking about
everything
and uh but on his way out
as woke is walking out the door feynman
stops him and says hey
i just have to ask you one thing have
you ever
do you know calculus and woke said well
no he never
studied it and so finance said well you
better learn it it's the language god
talks
and that then became the title of a book
that herman woke
wrote about his conversations about
science and religion
with a variety of scientists over the
years and philosophers and other people
so anyway why why did i tell that story
at the beginning of the book
um because it does a couple of things
for
for the book i feel one is it sets up
this really uncanny
idea that there is a language of the
universe
and that that language is written in
mathematics
and specifically a particular dialect of
mathematics calculus
and even more specifically the sub
dialect of differential equations
so i wanted to tell the story of how
we as a species have come to understand
the workings of anything that changes
smoothly in time or
space by um learning
this weird language of calculus that you
know as feynman said
feynman doesn't really explain what he
means about the language god talks but i
think any working physicist or
mathematician understands
that you know the laws of fluid dynamics
the laws of gravity
even quantum mechanics all these laws
are written
as differential equations and so he
urged
woke you know if you're going to write
about the atomic bomb you better learn
calculus
but the other thing i like about woke is
that he stands in
for the general reader in my mind that i
woke goes on to tell
that he tried to learn calculus he took
feynman seriously
and he had a real heck of a time
learning it he could not
you know he's tried reading books with
titles like calculus made easy it didn't
work
he went to a high school class he
started falling behind
you know i mean he really tried and so i
felt like the reader i have in mind is
someone who would like to know what
calculus is about or they're curious or
maybe they even took calculus but never
saw the point of it
um that's who i'm writing for someone
who
who is openhearted and wants to learn
but who is really mystified by every
exposure to calculus they've had so far
yeah that meshes nicely with my mission
on the into the impossible podcast i
always say it's to
deconstruct the tactics of the taciturn
you know because the old joke steve this
this holds doubly true for applied
mathematicians
is that how do you know an applied
mathematician is outgoing
because he looks at your shoelaces when
he talks to you
but actually i've had on nine nobel
prize winners i had on
jim simons who's a renowned
mathematician and philanthropist
obviously
but also you know even pulitzer prize
winners astronauts and
very few of them are able to communicate
uh these ideas to the late
lay public and i feel like you know i've
kind of gotten up maybe a little bit off
the deep end steve you should you should
you know step in and intervene as you
see this but actually i keep saying it's
a moral obligation
we get paid by the taxpayer by you know
my case the state of california as well
as a public uh servant to uh to to study
and do things that we do for fun the joy
of what you do is evident not only in
the title of your books but
but in your exuberance and your
irrepressibility which is so infectious
but we you would do it for free of
course
right sure is that you studied how to be
um like i had neil degrasse tyson on
last week he was talking about how much
he
studies the craft of storytelling
should we make it a requirement along
with partial differential equations
mathematicians and scientists have to
learn how if nothing else to communicate
to the people who pay their salary
that's a very interesting thought we
don't we never even consider that do we
and yet you know i am actually doing
that not as a requirement but we're
offering a seminar that we call
the mathematical communication seminar
and i've got grad students and faculty
and postdocs coming to it
it's a small group maybe 15 20 people
but we are trying everything
to get better at this we've we um watch
videos on youtube of people giving
fields metal addresses or nobel
acceptance speeches or
just ordinary colloquium or you know
like in other words we try to
analyze what's working or not we we read
some of the best writers
we think about going on tv or radio how
do you get your message across
crafting the so-called elevator pitch in
one or two minutes
anyway so we're trying to think about
all aspects of written and spoken
communication and we don't really know
what we're doing because there's no
textbook for this i mean it's
we're all just winging it using our
instincts and using the best role models
we can find to try to imitate
but yes the short answer is yes i wish i
don't know about requirement but
i totally agree with you that it's um
it's a moral obligation it's also good
strategy
if you want to be a successful scientist
if you can communicate well
i mean of course you have to have the
chops you have to be able to do the good
work have creative ideas
have the technique to solve the problems
that you're trying to solve have some
luck
even with all of that if you can't
communicate
you're not going to get the grants
you're not going to get your papers in
the best journals your colleagues aren't
going to understand or appreciate what
you're doing as much
as if you could really get your point
across right
i feel like it's a baseball you know
it's like major league baseball where
you know we're just teaching them how to
hit home runs or run around the bases
you know when you hit a home run but
we're not teaching all the soft skills
all the you know kind of
just blocking and tackling to mix
metaphors
but uh now you're also a pot we're gonna
get into some serious red meat i hope
for my uh or
some tofu
uh don't worry uh stay tuned because i
have some uh real-time calculus which is
always very dangerous to do
but i have some actual real-time
non-linear dynamical questions to ask
the world's most foremost expert stephen
strogatz who's my guest today
on into the impossible before i do that
you've interviewed a lot of the most
brilliant people around the world
for uh your joy of acts podcast for
quanta can you
talk a little bit about quanta i was a
guest i was honored to be on it
yeah wonderful thank you for being part
of it
i think your standards have certainly uh
risen since that time
tell me what is that like and have you
noticed this too with these brilliant
intellects that you know you have to do
a lot of coaching and kind of get them
out of their shells and
really make interesting what is
fascinating uh in these interviews that
you do and
and you do it so well first of all you
had no training in that right it wasn't
of course not
no yeah no i well thanks
i'm glad you you feel that it's working
we would love to have more listeners
so if any of your listeners will give us
a try that would be great
but it's really hard for podcasts to be
discovered or to be noticed there's a
lot of
people trying hard out there and there's
a lot of fantastic
you know things to choose from big
investment of time for people so we
understand why it's difficult but
as far as how to get people to open up i
don't know i
i mean i like to talk to people about
their lives often if you get someone
talking about their mentors
you know their beloved teachers or even
their parents
it softens people up they will they will
get out of lecture mode which is the
default mode for all of us professors
and researchers
and into just warm human connection mode
so um i usually like to start with
something soft like that but it
and then i also don't prepare very much
i don't know about you but i
i found that when i prepared a lot that
i would
i wasn't listening as well if i didn't
know what was coming like for instance i
had frank wilcheck who i think you also
maybe interviewed recently is that right
i was yeah i did i was going to ask you
about that specific podcast that and
when you had him on tv yes well so i
mean frank
has done such magnificent work in
physics
and cosmology or at least with
implications for cosmology some of his
stuff potentially if he's right about
dark matter and and axions but i mean
when
i was talking to him i just wanted to
stroll down memory lane
about his work on asymptotic freedom
what is the nature of the force that's
holding quarks together inside the
nucleus
and um you know why don't the protons in
the nucleus just repel each other i mean
they are they're trying with their
electromagnetic repulsion but the strong
force is holding them together
even more tightly so anyway and i have
never studied nuclear physics not really
and so i didn't know anything much about
quarks and jets and
asymptotic freedom so i went in as a
beginner just knowing the words but try
and frank explained it all very clearly
to me but
um along the way he talked about his
father in very affectionate terms his
father who hadn't gone to
you know really certainly not college
i'm not even sure if his father finished
high school
um so it was it was a really warm
nice discussion but then by the end at
some point after frank had finished
explaining work he did as like about a
21 or two-year-old graduate student
you know and he's now probably 70 or so
he's like
well you want to hear anything i've been
doing since then and i did and then he
knocked my socks off by telling me
in a very um slow burn kind of way
i didn't see where he was going he was
but anyway it ended up that something he
thought of might explain
dark matter in a very natural way that
would grow right out of the standard
model
so and i didn't see that coming and you
can hear when you if you listen to that
podcast you'll hear my audible surprise
like oh my god what you know like you
saved the best for last i said to him
because
i had no idea we were going to be
talking about dark matter so
i don't know i mean what i'm saying is
by not preparing
it gives a genuine connection if you
really listen to the guest
but of course it also makes it kind of
meandery which might be a deficit
in our show i mean if i maybe if i had
more structure it would be better
i don't know yeah well i find them
really delightful and what's so great is
that sometimes you'll just like the
interview with dygraf who is the
director i think of the ias
an institute for advanced study and then
all of a sudden he starts talking about
art
and and why visual art is not as deep or
effective or emotional as uh
as music and you guys start going into
this discussion of why
you know you can get moved to tears by
music by some notes of music
a score he talks about classical music
but it can hold for anything
but you never start crying ah the mona
lisa i mean you might
it's interesting isn't it it is it's so
i mean that's just
going off on it and it made me think and
i want to get your opinion you know
really
really on this as well but like if
that's true then
by dimensionality in other words music
is one dimensional that was kind of the
thing that
that you guys came to the like you have
to get it revealed at the pace that the
author wishes you to experience it
because it's a musical one-dimensional
you know format art visual painted art
like this thing over here is
two-dimensional
but then maybe i was thinking like is
three-dimensional sculpture like
less less moving or more like how do you
think about
that and then i started to think what
would a four-dimensional creature
what kind of art would they produce but
i find it so interesting you don't have
to react to that but
i mean i do have a little reaction i
don't even really remember especially
what robert and i said but to me the
thing about music is time
the music unfolds in time and
and art well of course film can unfold
in time cinema literally meaning
something about motion
but but snapshots or pictures on the
wall
really are at a disadvantage in terms of
emotional power because
time is that i mean robert and i did
start talking about this that
the time is the emotional dimension much
more so than space
and i think because of memory because of
loss
because of dreams of the future these
are all things that have to do with the
time with
time as a dimension and also the
our mortality you know that we we get to
live for a certain amount of time
but we can move through any part of
space yeah i wanted to talk about that
and keep
on this theme because i've had you know
carlo revelli on the podcast
and he has a book the order of time
many people i have some folks coming
brief history of time i had on
not stephen hawking although i would
have loved to but i had on his closest
collaborator leonard milan now
and they talked about their writing and
steven et cetera and now i've got a lot
of
folks coming up like julian barbour and
others
but um and a lot of these thoughts that
people are thinking about have to do
with time and i think
of it in terms of of course entropy and
this is where
i'm going to tap into your expertise so
stephen is
is perhaps known for i mean you're known
for so many things i mean you're the
father of you know
along with duncan watts the your student
the uh you know small network
of small world theories and and uh
network analysis network science i think
it's called now with a
paper that has over 45 000 citations at
last check i think it's
it's growing exponentially as we speak
but but i started to think of
these all these interviews i've done
interviews with stand-up comedians
and i start to think like um it's
interesting because
time according to carlo and frank frank
will check on as you mentioned
you know frank's basically his thesis is
that you know time
is what we call things that clocks
measure
and measure things changing and of
course that's related to the
second law of thermodynamics and if
there was no change or you were at
absolute zero
you'd experience no time change and so i
asked the comedian once i said
uh is it easier to make people sad
or angry or to make them laugh because
there are actually many more ways i
could make you
sad right now steve
please like the state of ways i can make
you i mean you're already very happy
you're at top university in the world
you've gotten all this acclaim you know
like it's very hard to make you
you could win the the um you know nobel
prize you could win
the lottery or so but those are very few
compared to all the ways
life could get worse for us i see where
you're going i see
and so i'm wondering interesting think
about these things like
how firmly rooted is that experience the
emotion
is it intimately connected with entropy
in other words
experience time is so painful or
melancholic
because it's associated with entropy
geez this is really deep and interesting
question
um yeah whoa i'm
okay
i mean i see where it's a really
interesting analogy you're making
because
we're taught in physics that when we
think of a state that's highly ordered
it's sort of like there are very few
ways it can be in
macroscopically like from the outside
there's only a few ways that you could
arrange the small parts the microscopic
configurations
geez i'm just using a lot of jargon it's
like in short
well okay but i mean plainer language
it's like you're almost saying
there's nowhere to go but down right if
you're too successful or if things have
worked out well for you in your life or
you've had a lot of luck
you get a natural feeling of concern
like my luck is going to run out
and that's because you're in this highly
negative entropy type state right i mean
you're in a very
abnormally ordered or lucky state and so
eventually the laws of chance will catch
up with you and your luck will run out
and uh you're going to get sad as a
result
so it's a really interesting analogy
but you're saying somehow the
wistfulness or the melancholy of time is
a direct
like emotional response to the second
law that things tend toward greater
entropy and
i don't know i mean certainly aging is a
kind of entropy
or uh you know or or is
i'm just sputtering i you caught me uh
not really knowing what to say you want
to help me out do you have some thoughts
you want to
give me some of some of your a couple of
follow-ups actually
yeah because of this this notion of
small world networks that you and duncan
your student
worked on you know a couple decades ago
it got me thinking a lot about
networks and uh for good and bad and
where i'm
eventually going to go with this is is
the relationship between entropy and
networks and i'm not
i'm just not clear if such a notion
exists but here's what i was thinking
along the lines of what i just said you
know i have a big family a bunch of kids
uh happy married and um but there's
there's
sort of i was making this argument you
know to a friend of mine who's single
he's a perpetual bachelor he's scared to
commit
he doesn't want to have kid you know
he's having fun with his girlfriend
i said you know you should not only get
married but you should have as many kids
as possible while you can
yeah there's some biological limits on
it as if if you don't know
but also i said i made the argument from
from network theory
so if you have um if you have a family
of size
n uh people then uh there are exactly
n choose two pairs of uh of
relationships of dynamics yeah and
they're all these like sayings and i was
trying to like
figure out can we construct the
thermodynamics of happiness
the entropy relate you know reduction
that occurs
when um when families have a lot of kids
and i've noticed that happy family like
big families they can be unhappy of
course but like
i come from my adopted family was a
family of 10
10 brothers and sisters you know and
they were the happiest people that i
knew
the keating side and i started thinking
like how many pairs of relate and so i
went through it and
you can do the math very easily uh and
it comes out you know for for that many
networks it's uh
it grows it grows basically
quadratically right with the number of
um so but the cost of having n
kids you know probably grows linearly at
the number of kids right
probably although in terms of
interactions between the kids that can
cause
it cause it to be difficult to deal with
them right right because sometimes they
have their own so
so there might be a little bit of
quadratic or even cubic terms in there
but but yes okay i'll take let's first
stipulate that
yeah probably the cost is proportional
to the number of kids roughly so you
only need one minivan you'll need one
house you only need
you know whatever that's true and some
of them are independent of the number of
kids
like the minivan it doesn't matter if
there's four or five right
they all yeah so sort of the benefit
because um there's a
there's a saying steve i'm sure you've
heard it like you're only as happy
as your least happy kid yes you have two
daughters
and you always talk so nicely about them
um but like if one of my kids is unhappy
yeah it's true
but is the converse true are you you
know can you be as happy as your most
happy kid
and if so would the happiness function
grow what i'm getting at
is you should have more kids because the
benefit
is n squared but the cost grows
so the n squared benefit is because
there's all these relationships so
you're sort of implying that
individual kids because they have more
opportu they have more
possible partners to goof around with or
have fun with or have heart-to-heart
talk with or whatever they need to do
and by the way they're going to spend
half their lives without us right i mean
yeah the average parent you know dies at
a certain age
and then the kids are left with
themselves their parents aren't right
well it's an interesting argument um i
it doesn't occur to me because you know
there are also other costs that you
put on society by having too many kids
though you could decide you don't care
about that and it's every
family for themselves um
i don't know i you know i mean we we
made the decision to have
two kids and stop because we thought it
was nice for them to have each other
which it has turned out to be you know
being in an ecosystem
a family with two people your own age
approximately to grow with
and to fight with and to just you know
all the things that make
life interesting seem to us
more desirable than um just having
one child or or zero uh i
kind of grew up effectively by myself i
did have a brother
and so i do have a sister who's still
alive my brother passed away but they
were much older than me my mother had
been married before
and then her first husband died and she
had these two little kids and then my
father
married her and then they tried for a
long time and eventually had me
so so my brother and sister were 12 and
10 years older than me so
effectively i was like psychologically
and only child
you know in the house nobody picking on
me nobody doing irrational stuff
it was a very in speaking of entropy i
mean everything was clean and well
ordered
and well regulated so what it meant was
like in relationships later in life
people would yell at me or get mad at me
or have fights with me
i was always pretty terrified of that
because i never had anybody picking on
me or
being crazy so i mean i think it sort of
set me back in a way like having
brothers and sisters around
i think is very developmentally healthy
for people to learn how to deal with
conflict and other stuff i
i didn't really have that yeah no it's
sort of the same argument i hear you
know where people shouldn't homeschool
their kids
you know because then they're only
getting exposed to you know this very
small small network and they're not
getting
diversity of opinion or backgrounds or
what have you
um but yeah that was just something
interesting i i wanted to run by you if
you thought it was totally crazy i'd
stop thinking about it but
um but i want to turn it back it's also
a linear cost to the person bearing the
children
yes right i mean maybe more than linear
because uh what is it like to have four
kids versus five
physically right i don't know i
that's so this might be a very
male-centric thing we're expressing here
how does your wife feel about the idea
of a large family
well i keep saying you know we're at
least halfway done you know once we hit
the
magic numbers that we um so maybe
turning away from families now back to
calculus
okay wonderful book although actually
before we leave that
is there a notion of like this entropy
come into play and at all in like
network theory or network science is
there like
with clustering i mean is it is it
beyond just like a
counting of states is there some way to
characterize classify a network
is a good question and i i haven't seen
people talking about entropy there are
ideas of curvature
i mean like you can have discrete
versions of curvature just like we have
continuous curvature
but um does entropy generalize to
network i mean we have entropy and
dynamical systems we certainly talk
about
aside from thermodynamics and classical
physics i mean even in non-linear
dynamical systems there are people that
calculate things about information and
entropy and
all that so those ideas do work outside
of statistical physics
but i haven't seen anyone use them in
networks that i can remember but it
seems
so natural it's such a powerful idea so
it must be i'm just not up enough on the
literature to give you
a good answer on yeah um getting back to
calculus um
so again you you're part of your mission
was to evoke herman woke who was like a
very educated i think of him as a
as a renaissance man in our century you
know he was someone who was
incredibly curious he actually ended up
writing a book as you know called the
language god talks
he wrote a book about the super
conducting super collider cancellation
he's a very brilliant and peripatetic
intellect uh
but i i forwarded you know your i gave a
copy of your book i bought
many copies one i gave to one of my
guests his name is
uh kamal rava khan he wants to learn
quantum mechanics
and and so i said well the only way to
learn quantum mechanics is to learn
calculus and the only way to learn
calculus from now on is going to be me
giving out copies of your book infinite
powers so i want to thank you for that
your book is based on and i gave it to
my father-in-law who knew herman
personally and he said um that this uh
that his
the eventual book that he wrote combined
herman's curiosity about physics and
mathematics
with his traditional jewish beliefs
beliefs about faith and god
maybe later if we have time i'll talk
about the proliferation of books
and things about god the god particle
the god equation
the mind of god all these god references
by
by atheist scientists mostly um
my gave my father-in-law your book and
he said um i've got i was surprised by
the reference
to herman woke and as i have gotten
farther into the book i am
overwhelmed by the author stephen
strogatz's skill
as a writer and a storyteller the
description of archimedes work and
humility is so amazing now my head is
full of triangles
also and this is you know he's not a
young man and he's a very brilliant but
he's not
inclined to mathematics whatsoever he
goes also there is a spiritual quality
about stephen's book
that brings together mathematical
discovery music art and the idea of
infinity
i wish that all mathematics could be
taught this way many of us who hit the
wall with calculus
those half steps would have made it
through if we had stephen
so i want to commend you on that and i
want to highlight this infinity
principle
first up i'm going to ask you a rapid
fire question can any
entity any mind known to exist
comprehend
the concept of infinity even a computer
can a computer
comprehend infinity well i'm sort of
stuck on the word comprehend there
i mean we can certainly define it in
various ways mathematically and work
with it
um i guess i'm thinking in terms of like
visceral
understanding versus intellectual
understanding
you know i mean i can i can operate in a
consistent way with various types of
infinity so to that extent i think
a pretty ordinary mind can comprehend it
in an operational way
but can you really absorb it in your
bones um
well i don't know that's that's that's
through the ages this has been something
that has inspired
all kinds of feelings and people dread
you know the fear of bottomless pits and
the abyss and i mean some people
say that that you can go crazy thinking
about infinity you know like that you
really shouldn't go there
so i don't know i mean it's tempting to
say no no human finite mind can really
comprehend infinity but i don't really
know what that means
mathematically it feels like we know how
to operate with it
my claim is that you know i'm not really
that worried about
uh you know alpha zero you talk alpha
infinity whatever
i'm not worried if computers can beat
human beings at chess
that actually doesn't concern me or i
don't think about that as an important
question because i know that's true
but i wonder can a computer create chess
can a computer create the game of good
in other words can it come up with the
idea of infinity i don't think it can i
think it's something unique about human
beings and that's why to me stephen
calculus is a uniquely human you know as
the old
someone once said some mathematician
you'll correct me that you know god made
the integers and all the rest is
mentioned
but i think but but only humans could
come up with calculus just like i think
only humans could come up with general
relativity only humans can come up with
things that are derivatives of calculus
no computer can't do do you agree or
doesn't sound right to me yeah i don't i
doubt that's true
um just on principle because i don't
believe there's anything
fundamentally mysterious about us when i
say
here the word fundamentally is doing a
lot of the work so
in other words i'm i'm a completely
materialist
person when it comes to this sort of
thing to me we're not
that different from the machines were
made of atoms
that came from stars you know we're
organized much more
brilliantly and in a sophisticated way
than any computer for now
so so of course we pat ourselves on the
back that were much
you know no computer could ever do what
we do but
we've been saying this for a long time
and we keep moving the goal posts you
know it used to be no computer whatever
beat us at chess
now that they've done that we regard
that as a trivial activity
you know so now we say no computer can
recognize a woman pushing a baby
carriage across the street they're still
terrible at pattern recognition
but they're going to solve that too
pretty soon and i mean i i'm i guess a
well like an optimist if you of course
it could be real trouble but i
i sort of think that the computers in
principle should be able to do
everything we do because we're made of
the same stuff and i don't think there's
anything
extra in us they're faster they have
better memories
you know they're just not there yet so
but if i'm wrong about that which of
course is quite possible if there's
something like soul
or you know a fundamental thing that
makes us human
like some some spirit of god in us like
if you were a christian
i don't know if the holy spirit would
come into play here but something that's
ineffable beyond pure
beyond physics then
sure then then computers will not be
able to do it because presumably they
don't have
what we have but i don't i don't believe
any of that i think we're
we're made of star stuff like everything
else
it's interesting i wasn't i wasn't
thinking to go there at least not this
soon in the podcast
uh because yeah talk about god and all
these ex i love that you do and that you
did
i was thinking more practically because
you say something okay so brilliant in
this book you say
when you see like an infinite like when
you see pi i used to think of it as
geometry but you said no it's calculus
no it is yeah
and i used to think natural logarithm
you say no think calculus
and i think just from a practical
standpoint you know one-third you can't
represent that unless you had an
infinite computer right so
one-fourth is perfect one-third is
perfectly fine if you work with
with fractions right one but if you want
to start
converting into decimals that's the
thing i mean because of being ten
fingered creatures we like to
massage our representations of numbers
into this decimal format
yeah one-third doesn't play that well
with decimals because it forces you to
take infinitely many threes after the
decimal point
but you know you get used to that and
also in the spirit of physics if you
just want a good approximation to one
third
you take as many threes after the
decimal point as you need and say good
enough
and actually it doesn't take that many
to get an approximation
better than you know the scale of the
planck length or whatever we think the
smallest amount of space or time
will be in physics so so for all
practical purposes you could compute
very well with
i mean i make that little calculation in
the book that if you measure the
the length of the biggest thing we know
say the diameter of the known universe
something you've thought about i know
and you taught me about actually i was
surprised actually when you told me it's
more than
two times the you know it's not just the
age of the universe
times the speed of light times two right
because what because inflation was going
so fast at the beginning
or even if there were some information
just the expansion of space itself is
taking place
independently of time or can take place
faster than the speed of light
because no signals are getting sent
there's no speed limit or that's right
but anyway we're off in a different
place there but but anyway
the basic point was i think still
correct that if you measure this whole
size of the universe its diameter in
terms of the smallest distance we know
the planck scale
of quantum gravity you need something
like 60 digits
so so in other words talking about pi
that's now computed to 50 trillion
digits
you know is big overkill if you just
want practical things but on the other
hand if you just want to think about
that's why real numbers are so unreal
right i mean there's nothing in reality
that corresponds to real numbers
but yet they're mathematically very
beautiful you can't really do calculus
without them
right so you you would think that uh i'm
surprised in some ways that you would
think that
a computer i i think of of things maybe
it's because of
your you know just profound expertise in
applied mathematics but
in the pure mathematical sense and again
just because
you're not a pure mathematician doesn't
mean that you don't know infinitely more
uh than i do about pure mathematics and
i guess i'm thinking of things again
with regard to entropy
in other words um there are many many
more unprovable things
than our provable things and and
especially given girdle
in the language of it seems to me that
girdle's theorem
combined with turing's proof of what is
and what is not computable
would suggest that there's really a tiny
number of things that are
computable in by by computational
standards and then layered
on top of that as an even greater filter
the paucity
of of things that are mathematically
self-consistent via girdle
would mean that there's almost like a
very small number of things that are
mathematically true and computable so
therefore how could a computer come up
with calculus like ab initio how could
how could an artificial galileo galilei
io come up with uh galilean relativity
or how could an artificial einstein
come up with the general theory of
relativity it seems like there is
something different it's not
it can't be purely computational thanks
to turing it can't be purely
mathematical maybe thanks to girdle
so how can you say um i sorry sorry to
sound like i'm on 60 minutes but
no it's good that you think that that
um you know a computer could you know
comprehend infinity or
could you know whatever comprehend means
or actually invent the concept of
enthusiasm
like just given i don't i mean for me
these questions are always easy to
because i can retreat to saying that
well a computer has done it
i mean we've done it because in this
belief that we're nothing special
with regard to this question that we're
made of particular
kind of you know wet wear the biologists
would say we happen to use
carbon and water and all that in our
cells instead of
silicon and we have our our neurons
running at
you know kilohertz or something instead
of
anyway i just don't see any real
particular obstacle that
computers have human computers have done
these things over
the course now okay here's the if i were
to push back against my own argument
i think the big the big deficit that
computers have is they don't have bodies
yet
right they don't get to move around in
the world and sense
the world the way that's our big
advantage we have bodies
with with interfaces we have ear drums
that vibrate when sound waves hit them
we have
fingertips that you know oh we have all
kinds of things we have eye
obviously you know eyes everything else
there is computer vision now
i suppose computers can hear i mean my
microphone right now is hearing me
um so once computers get better
at censoring sensing the world and get
to move around and have
the other thing is emotions right that's
interesting too
computers at the moment have been have
not as far as we know been imbued with
emotions
and we have desires including the desire
to understand to think to create
um they don't have any of that so that's
they're really missing a lot of
important stuff and so yes they haven't
thought of calculus yet
they have proven theorems in very
creative and even elegant ways
they've been told to do it they haven't
been taught how to do it i mean they've
actually invented
see this is why i get emotional about
computers
because i am a very active and
interested chess player and when you see
the games of the best
chess programs now they don't play like
machines anymore even though they are
machines
they play in this very romantic
swashbuckling style
sacrificing material they look like
they're imaginative now you could say
that's just
stupid of course they're not imaginative
they're just machines
but they but then what are we i don't
know i mean we look we think we're
imaginative too but we're just using
parallel processing or
anyway i'm kind of sputtering but i just
i kind of don't see the argument for
anything particularly special about us
you can also go in the other direction
when i think about my dog when i see the
emotions on my dog's face i know i'm not
kidding myself
people will some people who don't have
animals will say
you're come on you're being you're being
soft that's not true your dog doesn't
feel anything
your dog doesn't really love you your
dog doesn't miss you when you're away
but anyone who has a dog knows that's
wrong that's not true
of course they do right so
dog makes it into the acknowledgments of
your of influence yes murray is in the
acknowledgments
murray was a very good companion for me
when i was walking
a lot and thinking about the book and
frequently dictating into my iphone
that's
that's my i'm under how you wrote your
book actually i mean
when you wrote um losing the nobel prize
did you type did you talk to yourself
and record it what did you do
a little of each i i did some of each um
you know sometimes in the shower it's a
little
inconvenient to to you know have a have
a notepad in there so i would record on
my iphone or
i had a bunch of notes and um yeah yeah
so
that's how i did it but i didn't have a
dog you know i only had three kids
running around
but uh actually that leads me into
something i've always wondered about
mathematicians when
feynman used to wonder about this as
well and i wonder how you think about it
um when you count let's say you're
counting to ten do you
like see numbers moving through the air
do you
are in your mind or do you count like
one two three because i know for me like
i have to sing the alphabet song
to get like what letter comes after how
do you visualize number how do you count
just practically speaking ask a
mathematician about numbers
what's that yeah counting why would i
count
um i think i would do like what you
described for me it would be sonic i
would hear it
and i same thing with the alphabet i
can't if you said where is l
in the alphabet or what comes after l i
would hear it in my head lmnop you know
like that
so so yeah it goes way back to childhood
and it's very auditory for me i don't
picture
the alphabet on the molding of my you
know first grade classroom like
so i don't see it but the math i do is
very visual
so i just like i like chess and i like
thinking about the pieces moving around
on their two-dimensional
checkerboard i my subject is dynamical
systems which is all about things moving
around either in real space
like planets in the solar system or
imaginary things moving around in an
imaginary space that we call state space
where each point represents the state of
a hard cell or of a population
or whatever bunch of concentrations in a
chemical reaction
basically the idea is to describe a
state of something you have to give a
lot of numbers
saying what's the concentration of this
and what's the voltage across that
membrane and whatever
you give all these numbers and each axis
represents one of those numbers
and you could have a hundred of them and
then you think of that as one point
that's an ordered hundred tuple you know
a hundred numbers
separated by commas and we picture that
as a point in a hundred dimensional
space
that moves around as the state changes
as time goes on
except we're not really picturing it i'm
taking liberties there what i'm really
picturing is three dimensions
and something's flying around in 3d like
a drone flying around in space
i have my imaginary point moving around
in 3d but i pretend it's kind of 100
dimensional
interesting so also thinking back if we
can go back to the to networks and
friendship and stuff like that one of
your
previous book on calculus was called the
calculus of friendship
which i haven't read but but i was
wondering if we could explore a concept
that
made me think of at least the title of
the book but but maybe some of the
work that you've done as well and
networks and and so forth
but that was this week's uh torah
portion and we should say we
we have talked about the torah in the
past but this week's torah portion
revolves around gossip
and the gossip uh that is engaged upon
can be manifest in a human being back in
these days at that time three thousand
years ago maybe
uh that you actually have a physical
symptom like your hand would turn white
it was called leprosy but they don't
really think it was leprosy they don't
know what it was
um but it made me think and actually
gossip is considered
the most uh one of the most awful sins
because
it's basically a sin that's impossible
to repent
for there's a famous story of a man who
told a
who told tales about his rabbi and they
were truth i mean
the whole point about gossip is that
it's true if it's false it's a lie and
so
it's it's sort of less less pernicious
but anyway
this man is telling a story about his
rabbi it gets back to the rabbi then the
guy
goes to apologize to the rabbi the rabbi
says um
uh you know and he says to the rabbi how
can i make amends to you i feel so sorry
uh for the harm that i've caused your
reputation and the rabbi says
um it's very simple just go to your
house and get a pillow the guy's like
whew i thought it was going to be a hard
a hard uh form of teshuva of repentance
and the rabbi says
when he brings over the pillow uh the
man goes okay here's a pillow i didn't
know you needed a pillow but here you go
on the rabbit no no just simply i want
you to cut it open
and uh go in the town square and just
shake it out and the man goes
okay fine if this will absolve me of my
sins
so he does it and then the rabbi goes uh
waits a couple minutes and says now go
pick up all the feathers and the
implication being that
it's impossible yes it's impossible to
redo that
but i wonder you know is that one of the
perils of networks and
and small or big is that you know there
is harm that these things can land at
any place and
they're almost irreparable and you see
that obviously with social media
and things that grow um you know virally
uh there are perils of these networks as
well
and i wonder you know are we a victim of
these networks are they kind of just
so ingrained you make the point you know
brain cells or neural networks act this
way human
uh social networks act this way are we
are they like the microbes you know
there's like more microbes than human
cells in the human body
are we like at the mercy of networks or
a network something we can master and
subdue
as as god says oh i worry about it a lot
i've been worrying about it a lot i
um wrote a little essay some years ago
people could probably find it on the
internet easily it's called too much
coupling
so so there was an edge john brockman's
group edge
um he asked scientists maybe you've
written for them too they
often could think uh who you it was your
agent i guess or
she is my friend and john brockman yeah
they they often ask
they've stopped doing it but they used
to ask at the end of every year what's
some question and then people would
answer the question
um and they would then frequently be
collected into a book
so one year i think the question was
what are you worried about
yes and i worried about too much
coupling
now what i mean by that is
coupling is a word that we use in
dynamical systems to
describe the influence of one thing on
another i mean i guess it comes from the
old days when you would have
two train cars coupled together by
you know iron that grips one to the
other so that they're attached
um we speak of a couple you know like
people who are
a couple they're connected so coupling
is is when two things are connected in
such a strong way that they can really
affect each other
profoundly and um
when you have instead of just
individuals you have a population of
individuals that are interacting like
people in a social network or like
species in an ecosystem or all the
different cells in your heart or
whatever
these are all coupled dynamical systems
now
we learn in dynamics that that often as
you increase the strength of coupling if
you let
the individuals hear each other a little
bit more or influence each other a
little bit more
there's often a phase transition when
something qualitatively
dramatically different happens that you
couldn't see coming
i mean an example is on the millennium
bridge in london
when people were walking across the
bridge on opening day it's a footbridge
if you've been to london you may have
walked across it it's a beautiful
thin footbridge but but on opening day
the crowd was so big
that they ended up setting the bridge
wobbling side to side
in a way that was very uncomfortable for
people and they had to hold on to the
railings and
but what was weird is that as the bridge
started to wobble people got in step
with the wobble because they've
that's a kind of common human reaction
when you're walking on a wobbly surface
that's going sideways like
if you stand up on a train that's moving
fast and it starts jiggling you may
you may spread your feet out wide and
walk in step with the vibrations of the
wobbling train
people walked in step with the wobbling
bridge and inadvertently pumped more
energy into the bridge which made it
wobble more
until eventually like whole vast crowds
walking in step not on purpose driving
the bridge anyway they had to close the
bridge
but and then repair it and now it
doesn't do that but
the point was that that the bridge
engineers couldn't see this transition
to
spontaneous synchrony when they did
tests of the bridge in their computers
simulations it didn't do this and it's
only because
later experiments showed it's only when
there were enough people on the bridge
it suddenly started to do this
below that nothing so when i worried
about too much coupling in this essay
what i was talking about is that we're
doing a lot of social experiments on
ourself
at global scale and we don't know what
the heck is going to happen in terms of
phase transitions
you know the internet has done this to
us now the pandemic is doing it to us
through airline networks
you know i mean viruses are traveling
across the world
nazis can find each other much more
easily than they used to
you know thanks to the internet all
kinds of things
and things that we can't even anticipate
now i'm sure attacks on the power grid
or other things
are all being made possible because of
this
enhanced connectivity that we are
walking right into
so i don't know what's going to happen
but i worry about it a lot
yeah i found uh i found that essay as
you're chatting and i was listening
as i you know work with my millihertz
processor
and you made this really kind of
ridiculous claim steve
uh i have to call you out on it as one
of the problems of
of uh of such of such coupling
this ludicrous idea that you know it
could lead to a worldwide pandemic
and i just want to give you the chance
to recant that
well right so this essay came out when
2013 or something like that
yeah no it was obvious of course i
wasn't alone in
imagining that this could happen and it
will happen again
i mean these things are just in the
nature of the modern world now
and and we haven't even yet endured the
worst of it
on the other hand there's been great
benefits for this interconnectivity
think of all the great
stuff you can watch on the internet now
or even this podcast that we're able to
do
and you can reach people so education i
think has improved in certain ways
because of it
i love being able to find great
performances by some of my old musical
heroes you know that's all there on
youtube now
so i appreciate some of that i got a
text
or a twitter message from the national
champion
of chess of nigeria he wanted to be
connected to
you know he wanted to play like a speed
chess game with me and i said well my my
rating is probably the logarithm of
yours
and i referred him to a cornell graduate
by the name of james altucher
who is a uh is a well-known podcaster as
well and so hopefully they'll play a
game and maybe
the world will be richer for it but
actually it comes to pandemics
um you know i was noting to one of my
friends at one point like during the
pandemic that
flattened the curve was really a
calculus notion
and and really that uh more people
learned
you know learned at least one thing
about about integral calculus
from uh from from the pandemic at least
uh but yes in in this notion of of kind
of the unbounded
uh power for good or bad of of networks
i think we have to be
we have to be quite quite careful i want
to ask you about about
math as a mathematician and this notion
that we have as i mentioned before i'm
having people like michio kaku on
i've had on um you know the colleague of
stephen hawking
who ends his great book a brief history
of time with an exhortation that if we
find the final theory of everything
we will know the mind of god and michio
kaku's new book is called the god
equation
what do you make of the fact that an end
of feynman's you know the language god
talks
what is this about you know this notion
of god is it just a stand-in or kind of
a call
out for authority's sake what is why do
physicists who are
mainly you know fellow members of the
national academy or american academy of
viewers
that those people are mostly secular
right so
what what is this notion of god why does
it come up so often what do you make of
it as a materialist yourself as you say
well i'm not sure why different people
do it i i found myself doing it
in in my writing and my wife pointed it
out to me
she said there's a lot of god in this
book yes she was reading some of the
chapters
and i was not really very intentional
about it but
a lot of the great scientists have been
religious
certainly kepler was i mean kepler
studied to be a minister
before he became kepler the astronomer
and mathematician
and and galileo who often is championed
by
atheists because of his standing up to
the church
or at least trying to for a while before
he had to recant
you know understandably otherwise get
killed like giordano bruno did
um galileo was as far as i can tell not
an atheist
a galileo seemed to want to reveal god's
handiwork he thought he was doing
something very
devout in in figuring out what god had
created in the laws of motion and
and um so he i don't think he found it
particularly i mean it's true that the
church was taking
some heat from galileo but the church is
different from god
i mean in his mind yeah so and and
similarly isaac newton
clearly was was very interested in god
and did
spent a lot of time writing biblical um
chronology trying to figure out when the
world was created and
anyway so you know what he claimed was
the biggest accomplishment steve
absolutely his work on the bible
well right because he told me
yeah he died as christ did a virgin he
claimed that was uh
i haven't heard this story yeah this you
know
but i've also found a lot of you know
what is thought about newton you know in
particular have you heard this story uh
steve that the law of gravity had to be
modified basically introduced this god
of the gaps kind of
injected himself into into the laws of
gravity to stabilize the solar system
against
the gravitational instability of
resonance phenomena so when the planets
every so often would come together
their orbital periods resonate and
they'd be they'll cause a dynamic
instability
and apocryphally newton injects god but
but actually a guest also by the name
stephen meyer
who's who's an intelligent designer i
should say
he pointed out that you can find and he
was a philosophy phd from cambridge he's
a very well respected philosopher
anyway he he points out that nowhere
does newton ever make that claim
yeah i don't believe i've never heard
that either yeah but i have heard that
from other from
actually who mentions that in in the god
equation
uh neil degrasse tyson mentioned it you
know it's i find both of them pretty
unreliable historic
historians i i don't would not listen to
neil or mitchu on a lot of things
honestly i think
i'd like to have some discussions with
both of them
[Music]
and i have and maybe i tried to be very
careful with the history i really did i
tried to read the best historians i
could find
you see it's interesting there's a lot
of mythology about our our heroes the
scientists
and we tell stories like you'll notice i
don't tell the story of archimedes
and the bathtub i don't tell the story
of archimedes getting stabbed by the
roman soldier
and saying after he says don't disturb
my circles
so much um apocrypha in the stories that
we tell of scientists so you really do
want to learn
from the from the historians who have
looked carefully at this and so i did
try to do that but but back to your
question why
so much god talk from people who don't
believe in god when we're thinking about
these awesome topics about the
the harmony of the universe it's natural
to start to become a deist
i mean or something some this feeling
that there is profound
mystery in the structure of the laws of
the universe the big question i mean for
me would be where do the laws come from
you know there's so much math in the
universe i say calculus is the language
of the universe
well how can that be you know why why
would it be like that
and i don't know that's a big one
you know i often resort to some kind of
multiverse style argument that the
universes that don't have properties
that are mathematical enough
probably are stillborn you know they
can't support structure
that's sophisticated enough to allow
life to exist to ask the question
so we just happen to be by luck whatever
that means
in a universe where it's all
mathematical that's not very satisfying
and i don't know if i really believe
that i can see why people want to say oh
because god made it like this
but then i can't really make peace with
that explanation either
so i don't know it's i'm it's all very
mysterious
we talked about this before right the
torah says uh
maybe you shouldn't ask about the
beginning
well the torah the torah is kind of
silent on it but the the rabbis in the
talmud the second only
i should say i mean is what i was
talking about with
the interpretation the midrash right
they said be careful you know which is
uh
a good thing that we don't follow it at
the nsf you know under
grant proposal renewal the talmud for
the grant proposal
but it is true there are so many myths
that you bust so beautifully in this
book including like this
the hatred of knivenets and the and then
the smallness of newton
although he was a character i think
there's a character but i didn't really
spend any time about the
so many calculus books would spend a lot
of time on the
rivalry or the the priority dispute
mainly between newton and leibniz's
followers
leibniz had a whole army of people
making the case for him i don't
leibniz himself seems to have been very
impressed with newton as he should have
been
i mean he he he tried his best to keep
up with newton and would send him
his best work but it became clear to me
as i read their original papers that
newton was really in a different league
he really was and that's why we talk
about newton and we don't really talk
about liveness they're they're an order
of magnitude a part in
mathematical depth leibniz was great but
newton is really unrivaled
maybe to me archimedes is in the same
league as newton einstein
not too many a lot of people like gauss
as a mathematician i'm not very partial
to gauss
i don't like gauss very much i like
euler though i would put euler in the
league with these other people
but there are only a few interesting oh
wow
oh have you not heard this about
mathematicians deified gauss
i don't like galaxy yeah i don't like
cows too much because there are stories
about gauss now these might not be true
but the stories are that frequently
gauss would
discover things and then keep them in
his drawer
and so over and over again young
mathematicians would come up with great
things oh look i've discovered
non-euclidean geometry well no you
haven't because i had it 20 years ago
you know so koshi's theorem well koshy
didn't really discover it gauss already
knew it
so gauss did this to a number of people
and i don't like that
not i don't appreciate that anyway yeah
he was kind of a pill it sounds like
just publish it you figured it out why
don't you publish it
and then especially that nicky thing
hiding it and then and then ruining it
for
the next person to discover it and
meanwhile the world could have been
farther advanced if you but you know he
had this expression few but ripe
that's what he would say the results
were few he would wait till they were
ripe
few but ripe wow i don't like it no that
would be great that would be another
good book and
my fantasy when reading this book was
like what if newton what if we we did a
science fiction fan
fiction book about newton if he never
was into alchemy
or you know spent less time you know
torturing counterfeiters
although you might not do you know this
that the why coins have ridges
do you know why uh like a quarter has a
really no i don't know why do they have
ridges
have you ever looked at a quarter so you
should look at a quarter because
they have ridges but pennies don't and
so what why does one
or a nickel a nickel doesn't have a
ridge right dime does
um and and so you go through it and uh
those are called flutes
or um there's another technical name for
them so back in
roman times when people realized and
actually this goes back even further
than that
but roman times what people would do is
they take a quarter or whatever it was
back then
a ducat or whatever they called it
florin and they would grind it down
and they would grind down the gold or
the silver coin and they would get off
just enough material
that they could eventually get enough
coins together they could have a whole
new coin
so it's called there's a form of
inflation
and it was a form of counterfeiting and
coin clipping
so for thousands of years this was a big
problem in fact it was a problem in
medieval
england in the early part of the second
millennium
so much so that our fellow jews were
accused of being
the ones responsible for it and led to
the jewish expulsion in the 1200s
of all jews from from england uh and
actually the problem was solved by isaac
newton
he realized he could take a coin and put
ridges on it
and then it could not be ground down
without
uh making it evidentiary to anyone who
looked at so actually and then
soon thereafter the junior permitted to
move back to to
uh to the land of england so it's very
interesting that he he did so many
interesting things
but i still would have liked to know
what would his life been like if he
didn't practice alchemy
and also you imagine how many things he
could have done he could have had a real
career
he could have been somebody could have
been a contender um
here's another thing that i can't help
but by the way i read this book twice
but
but the first time i read it it was slow
and leisure the second time i read it
just recently i read it in like a day
it's such an e and it's 300 pages it's
not like like some
lightweight book steve and it's not you
know it's a book with a couple equations
but not too many some series some
equation um
but you know as i'm reading it i'm
thinking well what if steve's wrong
you know he's been wrong before about
this pandemic no that's for sure
what if there's something that stands in
relation
to calculus as calculus does to you know
algebra or linear
whatever are we sure we have the final
theory of
oh yeah i don't make any claim about
that no i know you don't but but
but what if what if there's even like
more than infinity
called the infinity principle is there
something is there possibility there's
your co-author no no there's your
your news
[Laughter]
could there be math that we just can't
discover or would universes that produce
higher order math be stillborn in the
multiverse of mathematics
oh i i expect there's a lot more math to
be discovered and
probably a lot of it will be beyond us
i do imagine a future where where
the greatest mathematicians are the
machines and they're discovering
fantastic things and hopefully they'll
become good
teachers that's what i'm really hoping
you know that they will
they will find ways or maybe we can
program them to have ways of explaining
things
comprehensibly to us so we can share in
the pleasure of their discoveries
but but i don't picture us being the
greatest mathematicians for much longer
um i think we're already seeing it i
mean there are a lot of examples now of
computer assisted proofs
they're also theorems being proven by
computers for the first time
so for instance there's there's a lot of
uh
a lot of results now like the famous
four color map
theorem you know that you could color
any map with just four colors so that no
two neighboring countries have the same
color
under certain constraints on what's
allowed as a map
that um the best proof of that took a
long time to prove it we we finally got
a proof i think in the 70s
um hawking and appel i think get the
credit for that first proof of the four
color theorem
but they found i mean other people
showed that there was a way to reduce
the
infinitely many possible maps to just a
finite but large number of possible
types of maps like there's certain
equivalence classes
of um of maps and if you could check
that the four color theorem was true for
each of those
types you would have proved the theorem
for all infinitely many possible maps
and
no human being was able to check all
those types but computers did
and so we now know that the four color
theorem is true
as of the 1970s but it's a big
disappointment to mathematicians because
we kind of already believed it was true
we wanted to understand why it was true
why does it have to be true
and we still the computers have not
explained that to us yet
and maybe they don't know why themselves
they're just calculating
and don't have any insight so that's
where i think the interesting future is
for math
and possibly for science is this
question of insight
like right now and ever since newton we
have cherished
insight that not only do our laws of
physics
and to some extent chemistry and biology
tell us what will happen but we can see
why it will happen like you know you can
explain kepler's laws with newton's laws
so we in that sense understand why
kepler's three laws are true
that they follow mathematically from a
deeper law
from newton's laws of motion and gravity
or similarly why newton's laws
you know follow from einsteins and stuff
like that so that's very satisfying when
we have that kind of insight
but i picture that the window is closing
on that
that that we won't have this kind of
insight for much longer
and but the computers might and then
we'll really feel left out
they you know anyway totally wild
speculation maybe all wrong
my friends in artificial intelligence
like actually melanie mitchell who's one
of my guests on joy of x
coming up in a few episodes she thinks
i'm completely wrong and that i ought to
take some computer science and learn
more
before i go mouthing off about ai and
i'm sure she's right
she says this is totally wrong computers
are not nearly as good as you think they
are
um but i i don't know okay anyway this
is what i currently think
well it's interesting that you say that
the last thing we'll say before we turn
to the
wind up uh the the episode in the book
you say something which i agree with
um you know as a physicist but i found
it surprising coming from a
mathematician
you said something like intuition comes
first and rigor comes later
as it did with archimedes so in other
words you go through this wonderful
example of calculating the area of a
parabolic segment
and um but you know it's sort of led by
intuition of course we couldn't prove it
until thousands of years later but i
always thought that mathematicians don't
rely on
intuition really that you know and that
we physicist
what we call proof and this will come
into play when we talk about string
theory in a minute but what we call
proof
is uh is really not up to mathematical
standards so
what what do you mean by you know
intuition comes first and rigor comes
second
why is that acceptable to a
mathematician but not to a physicist
okay so there's a lot going on in that
question first let me just say
archimedes did prove
a formula for the area of a parabolic
segment just to remind people what that
is so that's if you cut across a
parabola with a line
making a shape that that is you know
some bounded region that has a parabola
on the bottom and a straight line on the
top
roughly speaking he's finding out the
area under a parabola
and and he can do it and he does it two
different ways and it's totally rigorous
and it would meet any
standard that we have today it's just
that he doesn't use the fundamental
theorem of calculus because that won't
be invented for another two thousand
years or so
but but he knows how to do it by adding
up
smaller and smaller triangles and taking
a limit
um he doesn't call it a limit but he's
using an
ancient technique that they called the
method of exhaustion that squeezes the
area
anyway these are details but but anyway
he
he had intuitive ideas about how to
solve the problem
just like every mathematician and i
think every physicist has
has a bodily feeling has a hunch has
experimental clues
you have something that is short of
rigor at first
you have an idea of what should be true
like we sometimes say it's morally true
like this really should be true but we
don't see why it's true
and so that's but but first comes this
feeling and often a desire
so it's not just a feeling or a hunch
but it's i want it to be true
because this thing is beautiful or this
thing is so cool i just want it to be
true
and so then you set out to find a reason
why it has to be true
and if you're lucky you're right then
your conjecture was correct and you
found a proof a series of
cold-blooded logical steps building on
axioms
or or in the case of physics building
unknown physical laws
that lead you by deductive reasoning to
the thing you thought was true
um but yeah hunches come first intuition
comes first i mean it's true you ask um
you know john lennon or somebody how
does he write imagine or
you know what's a great show song
exploder do you know this show
song exploder is an interesting show you
can watch um
i think it was a podcast actually and
musicians talk about how they wrote
this famous song like the guys in rem
talk about how did they write losing my
religion
you know or how does anyone do anything
creative and they tell you well i was
just playing around on the ukulele and i
thought this was kind of a really cool
thing it wasn't the song at that point
it was just a glimmering right so
so it's all like this with everything
how does a poet write a poem they don't
just sit down and write it they have a
feeling
so it's the same in math you have you
have um
some intuitive desire and a vision of
what you want to create
and then you have to have the technique
to create it and in math that technique
is rigorous proof
or calculation or whatever sure
so um just finishing up with that and
then circling back to
richard feynman and his conversation
with uh herman woke who
we began the podcast with richard
feynman said i don't care how beautiful
your theory is how it uh what beautiful
math it uses
if it doesn't agree with experiment it's
wrong
in the case of physics obviously that's
that's something
that's one standard but i've had many
guests kameron vapha comes to mind
uh who have said things that essentially
string theory
is is too beautiful to be wrong and that
uh
in the everlasting enduring uh time
capsule question which i will soon
uh he answered he would put the
equations of string theory on a monolith
to launch into outer space for all time
i want to ask you you know what about
this where do you
fall as an applied mathematician you
know kind of hybrid between
the physical universe that i explore
with colleagues in
in the purely theoretical mathematical
world of physics or math
um what about things like michio kaku
says you know that
you know there's 10 to the 500 different
string theories and
you have to tell me what the initial
conditions are but you can't tell me
because the initial conditions vary from
universe to universe so
are we just lost uh it's been said that
you know
the math of string theory is from the
21st century
or the 22nd century and it fell into the
20th and 21st century
now what do you make of this do you
think that string theory is too
beautiful to be wrong
uh sort of morally true as you just said
well i so this is way outside anything i
know about so you shouldn't pay
any attention to what i have to say i
don't know
straight never studied even quantum
field theory so i'm certainly in no
position to talk about string theory
um but as a just a general matter
that's a disturbing point of view the
idea that something is too beautiful to
be wrong
there have been a lot of beautiful
theories that have turned out to be
wrong
so i'm surprised at my physics friends
who say that
it certainly turned out to be i mean in
math a lot of
great math has come about as a result of
string theory
for instance there's this great um thing
about not theory
the jones polynomial which ed whitton
figured out a deep
explanation for this cool invariant of
closed curves that have knots tied in
them
the jones polynomial is kind of an
oddity that worked but we didn't really
understand why it had its miraculous
properties
and then whitten was able to kind of
embed it in a deeper theory
that explained where the jones
polynomial was really coming from
and i think and i may be wrong about
this but i think it was some insights
from string theory that gave it to him
so this didn't really help or maybe it's
topological quantum field theory that
gave it to them i don't know
but the point being beautiful physics
may really help us in math as to whether
it helps us understand the universe
sometimes yes it did with general
relativity
um sometimes no there have been
beautiful
so like so far the jury's out on super
symmetry
right super symmetry seems to be
beautiful but we're not seeing it yet
in in our experiments as far as i know
so it could be that it's wrong i mean
this may be that our universe isn't
built that way i don't know
um but it's still worth studying that's
the thing
just the the love of beauty has usually
been a good guide
it may not be our particular universe
but we'll learn things by doing it and
it will at least give us some really
cool math and it may give us
some really cool physics i don't know i
i don't i don't
begrudge the physicists working on
string theory for that reason
but um
it does yeah it does yeah it does yes
and there are some that say you know it
hasn't led to you know so anything
as nathan cyborg said you know if if we
discover something
beyond string theory we string theorists
are very arrogant we'll call it string
theory
and in fact i had that on my podcast
recently these discoveries of the muons
anomalous magnetic moment
so-called g-models 2 and and phenomena
like this
large hadron collider beauty quark
discovery that
indicates a fifth force so as soon as
this is as soon as the result comes out
strength errors will say yes that's what
string theory would tell you
but no one ever looks into the string
theory and says oh here's where this is
going to come apparently because there
are too many
potential initial conditions that each
one can produce a different value for g
minus 2 or something like that so it's
it's
you know it's a conundrum as i say i
actually asked michio kaku
this before i said well you know you're
very gung-ho and bullish on string
theory but what if you're the
director of the nsf and you get two
proposals and one is for
string theory and one is for not you
know minus
you know whatever theory or strogatz
theory
and uh and don't find that
fun both he said and i said well you
know that's that's a nice
you know kind of saying i'll have the
chicken you know if you can't decide
between the fish and the tofu
but anyway stephen i want to uh i want
to thank you and i want to ask you also
if you are willing to go into the
impossible and answer the three
trademark patented
that i ask all my beloved guests and uh
you would be no exception i want to
ask if you are willing to play the into
the impossible thrilling three final
questions let's do it okay sure why not
okay
so the first one involves what we uh in
judaism call a zava ah
or an ethical will and it's actually not
too dissimilar from
something that alfred nobel did he had
no children no wife
no heirs of a direct lineage and so he
left all of his money to those that
benefited mankind in other words it
wasn't just
a material will to benefit their bank
accounts it was to benefit
uh all of mankind sort of unique and in
judaism
there are many examples of this uh and
uh and one of which is of course
jacob blessing his children and moses
the book of deuteronomy anyway i don't
get too religious here although i'd love
to do that with you separately
as you know my rabbi said after my
interview with you on the joy of acts
and your wonderful podcast to which
everyone should subscribe
rate review and um and do whatever you
can to support it i love that podcast
it's one of my regular rotations
but he said you and stephen should
become uh should become
uh you know study partners in tory we
should be that would be fun
havrusas which means uh friends uh but
it's nice and i've learned so much from
you it
it's it's kind of a temeritis for me to
suggest that i could teach you anything
anyway steve this is a long way of
saying when you reach the biblical age
of 120
years hence what do you want to leave
the world your biological
but also your ideological errors in
terms of wisdom
or teachings that you've learned
ah well um
on my twitter page it says
all cards up face up all the time
and that was something that my friend
charlie marcus said to me once
um he's a physicist actually working on
quantum computing
and he actually will be another guest as
a term you know how it is you invite
your friends onto the show right
so yeah charlie marcus is coming up in a
few weeks on on the joy of x but charlie
said that about me that
man with you it's all cards up you know
all cards on the table face up all the
time like no filter
no nothing secret and i i'm reminded too
of
my high school yearbook quote you know
how it is in your high school you have
to pick out something to put in the
yearbook and you don't know
because you're at such a formative stage
in your life you don't really exactly
know who you
are and what would you want people
all those years later they're going to
look at your photograph
oh i remember that guy so you know then
you want
you want some little saying or something
a song lyric that's going to capture who
you were at the time
so i think was it in high school or was
it in college i can't remember
but the one that seemed right to me at
the time was a quote from mark twain
who um who said if you tell the truth
you don't have to remember anything
i kind of like that one i still like
that one if you tell the truth you don't
have to remember anything you don't have
to be cunning you don't have to be full
of guile
just tell the truth and um
it's a little easier it's a little more
efficient it's not always
the compassionate thing to do so i don't
want to go too far
you know telling the truth in unpleasant
circumstances can be mean um
so you have to temper it but
i also i also like this line from mark
kotz
so that's of cots feynman cots formula
kac a polish
mathematician mark kotz said with regard
to teaching
um tell the truth
and nothing but the truth but not the
whole truth
right a little play on what we make
people say in court
you know tell the truth and nothing but
the truth but not the whole truth
the student the beginning student you
shouldn't be lying to the student for
the sake of simplicity you should just
tell the truth
and and no lies but you don't have to
tell the whole truth that's going to be
too complicated at first
it takes a while to absorb the whole
truth so
so don't lie but don't tell the whole
truth first
and this is something in your interview
with shane
something or other on the knowledge
project the farnum street
podcast from a couple of years ago yeah
shane perry's you said something
beautiful it was like
give students and this echoes john
mather winner of the 2006 nobel prize
his advice uh from david wilkinson who
is my advisor's advisor
he said you know get good students and
give them impossible problems
but don't tell them they're impossible
and you said almost the exact same thing
so
i thought it was beautiful uh this this
role that you that you
so wonderfully exemplifies an educator
wow
david wilkinson man that's so cool that
you're connected to him i
he was a freshman physics teacher back
when i was taking physics at princeton
that's right yes and i think we talked
legendary teacher
yeah yeah he's uh he is
sorely deeply missed i have an interview
i'm doing an interview one of my
interviews in a couple of months
a couple weeks ago i did was with my phd
advisor peter timby
who was who was uh his student as well
so he was
he was uh my conduit to uh to david
wilkinson
so we talked a lot about david and about
people like
um uh like robert dickey and other
people
yeah that'll be fun
okay so next steve i ask all my uh
beloved guests
what material object or knowledge would
you put on your monolith
and the monolith is meant to be
evocative of these structures in
arthur c clarke's 2001 a space odyssey
these menacing kind of things that are
placed around the universe and sprinkled
around
meant to be found when humanity has the
capability to understand it by some
unseen
ancient alien civilization now we agreed
by rule of nasa that we're not going to
talk about the alien autopsies but
if you were going to leave time capsule
what would you put
in it or on it or what would it be about
and i could give you feynman's answer
your fellow or former
cornell uh he used to say it was the
cataclysm
question he said it was the atomic
hypothesis everything is made of atoms i
wonder what would you say
what would encapsulate the most
information about the physical or
mathematical world
that kind of you'd use to brag you used
to flex
on future civilizations yeah well um
it's certainly not my discovery or
anything like that just as the atomic
hypothesis is not exactly finements
either
but but i seed magazine which doesn't i
don't think exists anymore
seed magazine was a magazine that was
about had the
tagline science is culture and
science uh was often portrayed in that
magazine
as a kind of a cool thing they would
have artists talking to
to mathematicians or scientists and it's
very interdisciplinary nice magazine too
bad it's not
printing anymore but once they did have
an article about
feynman's quote about the atomic hype
the cataclysm
uh question or whatever you want to call
it what would you leave if the catechism
were going to cut you know it was going
to come
what one sentence would convey the most
information
so i i actually was asked that question
at that time
and wrote something into seed which is
what i would still answer today
which at the time i didn't have a name
for it but now i would call it the
infinity principle
i think that would be my answer that to
make sense of anything
that changes smoothly any any shape any
motion
any process any phenomenon no matter how
wild it is break it up
into infinitely many infinitesimally
small
straight pieces that behave like
constants
and then solve the problem for those
little pieces and then put the answers
back together again to make sense of the
original whole
so that that principle is the essence of
calculus
and yeah i think it's one of the
greatest ideas humanity's ever come up
with so
that's that would be it for me in contra
distinction to feynman's answer
because if the atomic hypothesis
suggests that there's an ultimate
what does adam stand for again
indivisible
uncuttable right so right
strogatz we'll see in two thousand five
hundred years which one
well his is probably right i mean the
atomic one is probably true
this one is not true this is a creative
fantasy
but it's such a powerful it's so close
to true and it's so fruitful
whereas his does not generalize that
well in math
yeah you can't do much with discrete
math compared to continuous math i know
that some people will say i'm nuts for
saying that
but i think time has shown that the
calculus
beats the pants off anything in discrete
math yeah
and i can't wait to see what comes after
calculus when we're in a
post-calculus universe um so steve we've
gone forward in time
to your leaving this mortar coil at age
120 we've got a billion years into the
future now we're going to go backwards
in time
again hearkening as i do to sir arthur c
clarke who's the namesake behind
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination here at uc san diego where i
co-direct it
along with my friends and and family
members uh
and that is his one of his laws he had
many laws the one of which is uh the
uh any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and
actually have his voice
saying those very famous words that open
every podcast as you'll hear
hopefully when you listen to the podcast
in a few weeks when it comes out
his second law applies to our fellow
members in the faculty club uh
ucsd and cornell and that is for any
expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
and his last law or his third law states
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible that's the origin of
this podcast name
and i want to ask you uh as a 20 year
old advice to your 20 year old self your
30 year old self what
aspect of life was most mysterious and
perplexing
what piece of advice could you give a
young steve
to give him the courage to do what
you've done to go into the impossible
uh well uh i
think of myself as the weakest math
major at the time
in college that that was an important
part of my self-image i would see the
other kids raising their hand before
mine would go up
they would see the answers they could
they could carry out arguments
more precisely go deeper and it was
discouraging
um to be around such smart people and to
feel
like maybe i don't have the right stuff
to do what
my dream was to be a professor and to
teach and to learn and
you know maybe discover something here
and there
and and it was it was a cause for
concern
and but princeton had a requirement
every senior had to write a senior
thesis
and i wrote about something i i was
interested in geometry but i also was
interested in the real world and
i thought about geometry of dna
molecules i i had been learning about
dna and biochemistry courses and biology
and
anyway um so i didn't know if i would
really be able to discover anything or
not about that but it turned out just
sort of through good luck and good
connection with a biochemistry professor
i kept going to him with ideas he would
say that's a terrible idea
you know and he'd send me away and and
my math professor
would my advisor would also say well you
know it's good that you're learning some
biochemistry
but i hope you'll come up with some good
math anyway i just kind of stuck with it
and eventually this biochemist a borsell
was his name abraham marcel
said if look if you really want a good
problem this is the problem you should
work on and he described a certain
question
to me he said everyone's breaking their
head about this if you could solve this
this would be good
and i said well i could do that this
afternoon and he said are you crazy
he was from argentina and he would get
very hot you know and jumping around and
he'd say dad you're crazy you don't
understand the first thing let me
explain it to you again
so he starts explaining it again but i
did understand it and it turned out that
all the suffering i had done up till
that point in the year
all my dead ends put me in a position to
understand his question
and it was actually an easy question if
you knew the right things
which i had learned in the course of
being stuck
and so i did solve it that afternoon and
i showed him and he was hopping around
the lab saying this is going to be
big and uh anyway so it was my first
paper and
the reason i'm telling the whole story
is my advice to my old self
would be don't worry about not being the
smartest
um love goes a long way
love of your subject love of your art
you know
and and the passion like you have to get
lucky which i did
but um but stick with it and love it and
don't worry there are always going to be
people smarter and better than you
but there's still a place for you
that's great to hear steve and it's it's
just so i mean i'm listening and i'm
thinking
you know i heard you once described
maybe in that same interview with shane
about um
you know how you approved this
conjecture in high school
to a mathematician who had gone to mit
or professor and then
no one had ever solved that he claimed
and then you solve this thing about
triangles something about triangles
and i'm thinking like this was the
weakest snap you know it solved like a
thousand-year-old geometry problem and
like
what hope is there for me but i think
i'm going to spin it around for our
friends at princeton and say
it's a testament to to the brilliance of
mathematicians
around the world that even steve didn't
consider himself the greatest of all
anyway you've gone on to influence the
world uh in such a positive way steve
you've
uh influenced me now you're influencing
my father-in-law
that's that's that's a gift that you
just cannot beat you know when you give
a guy something that he can give to his
father-in-law
teach him something that his son-in-law
son-in-law's not a stupid [ __ ]
uh steve i want to thank you so much
you're really you're such a mensch as i
call
you uh the math mathematics mensch but
um but i i really i just appreciate you
so much and i'm so glad that you
don't keep all your discoveries to
yourself like that hateful gauss
not only your mathematical discoveries
of which you know steve is you know
by some counts one of the most cited uh
physicists in history
uh and and as a mentor and studies the
art and craft of science presentation
you can find his
lectures all over the internet but i
please want
everybody to subscribe to the joy of x
even if it means
you know not what not listening to an
episode here and there of this podcast
into the impossible please do that leave
a rating for steve
on itunes and um and steve bachmann
thank you so much and
and i do hope we'll meet in person
someday me too brian you
are in ithaca thank you this is a really
beautiful interview and
fun conversation it's going to be great
when we get to do this in person thanks
a lot for having me
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoy this video click here
[Music]
you